สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะ
นะขอต้อนรับนะคะนักเรียนทุกคนเข้าสู่ห้อง
เรียน comprehensible  Thai ห้องเรียน
ภาษาไทยด้วยการฟังค่ะค่ะแล้วก็วันนี้
เนี่ยครูปุ๊กกับครูชิก็มาพบกับนักเรียน
ทุกคนนะคะนะในวันนี้วันอะไรคะครูชิชิชิ
วันจันทร์ค่ะ
วันนี้วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ 26 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะ
กุมภาพันปีพ.ศเท่าไหร่คะ
2567 ปีค.ศที่เท่าไหร่คะ
2024 ค่ะค่ะแล้วในวันนี้เนาะวันจันทร์
วันที่ 26 เดือนกุมภาพันธ์ปีพุทธศักราช
2567 ปีคริสตศักราช 2  24 ค่ะเราก็มาพบ
กันนะตอนนี้ก็พบกันบ่อยๆหน่อยนะอค่ะเนาะ
เออครูชี้คะปีนี้ร้อนมั้ยคะร้อนค่ะร้อน
มากเค้าบอกว่าปีเนี้ยจะร้อนมากกว่าปีที่
แล้วค่ะโอปีนี้เนี่ย
2000  567
ใช่มั้ยคะจะร้อนมากกว่า
2566 ค่ะอือ
ฮึอันนี้ร้อนร้อนมากแล้วก็จะร้อนมากขึ้น
เนาะในเดือนนี้เนี่ยเดือนกุมภาพันธใช่
มั้ยนะใช่ว่าเดือนหน้าก็เหมือนกันค่ะนะ
เดือนหน้าเนี่ยมีนาคมเนี่ยเดือนที่ 3
เนาะก็จะร้อนมากกว่าเดือนกุมภาพันธ์ค่ะอื
อืทุกปีทุกปีนะคะเอ่อหน้าร้อนเนี่ยจะมา
ประมาณแบบต้นๆมีนาคมนะแต่ปี
เนี้ยกุมภาพันธ์น่ะก็เริ่มร้อนแล้วอ่ะอ
ยังไม่ถึงมีนาคมเมษายนซึ่งประเทศไทยจะ
ร้อนมากที่สุดคือเดือนที่ 4 นะเมษายน
โอ้โหไม่รู้ว่าจะร้อนมากแค่ไหนเเาโอ้โหก็
ใกล้จะไป 50 ทุกทีแล้วแต่มันดีที่ว่าไม่
ใช่ว่าทั้งวันนะ 50 องศเซซเไม่ใช่นะมันก็
จะเป็นช่วงเวลาเนาะตอนนี้ก็จะแบบน่าจะ
อยู่ประมาณสัก 46 กว่าๆที่ที่วัดได้ในที่
สูงที่สุดในประเทศไทยเนาะนะสูงที่สุดไม่
รู้แล้วแต่จังหวัดนะแต่ละปีไม่เหมือนกัน
ก็ได้หรือจะเหมือนกันก็ได้นะอุณหภูมิ
เนี่ยมันจะสูงที่สุดที่วัดได้น่าจะอยู่
ประมาณซัก 40  4
45 แต่ปีนี้อาจจะไป 46 หรือเปล่าตายแน่ๆ
นะคะตายแน่ๆแล้วปีเนี้ยเขาบอกว่ามันไม่มี
น้ำค่ะน้ำใช้เนี่ยเหลือน้อยลงน้อยลงแล้ว
ก็คิดว่าจะไม่มีน้ำเนี่ยสำหรับทำนาน้ำ
สำหรับไปปลูกข้าวนะจะน้อยลงนะอโหแต่แต่
ครูชิเเนี่ยเปิดทีวีนะแล้วทีวีก็พูดถึง
อากาศพูดถึงโลกใบนี้นะแล้วก็พูดถึง
อุณหภูมิแล้วก็อากาศเนี่ยแล้วก็บอกว่าวัน
ที่นะคะที่วันที่ 20
กุมภาพันธ์มีนะค
กุมภาพันธ์จะ
มีฝนตก
อ่าก็มีก้อนเฆแล้วก็มี
ฝนพายุฤดูร้อน
อืมีพายุุฤดูร้อนเพราะว่าถ้าเกิดที่นี่
ร้อนใช่มั้ยที่นี่ก็จะลอยไปที่นี่
เย็นจะพัดมาบางทีพัดมากๆมันเกิดพายุอ่ะ
พายุใช่ก็มีคนบอกว่าช่วงที่เกิดพายุจะมี
พายุฝนด้วยอ่าอะไรคะเนี่ยพายุฤดูร้อน
เนี่ยเป็นพายุที่น่ากลัวค่ะเพราะว่านะ
อากาศเย็นจากทางภาคเหนือเนาะของประเทศเรา
ก็อาจจะเป็นจีนเป็นอะไรเนี่ยเคก็พัดลงมา
นะร้อนจากใต้ก็ขึ้นไปเจอกันอยู่ตรงกลางพอ
ดีค่ะนะอยู่แถวๆเอ่อประเทศไทยนี่แหละค่ะ
นะร้อนอากาศร้อนก็ลอยตัวขึ้นสูงเนาะที่
ครูชิบอกนะพอไปเจออากาศเย็นปุ๊บมันก็กลาย
เป็นแบบลมนะเพราะว่าลมเนี่ยสิลมเย็นเนี่ย
มันก็จะลงมาแทนที่นะความร้อนลอยขึ้นเย็น
ก็ลงมาแทนมันก็เลยเกิดเป็นลมใช่มั้ยลมพัด
เย็นสบายแต่อันนี้เนี่ยปรากฏว่ามันเป็นลม
ที่แบบเหมือนจะมีฝนเนาะแต่น้ำฝนเนี่ยมัน
กลายเป็นก้อนมันเป็นน้ำแข็งค่ะอื้อหือ
เป็นน้ำแข็งแล้วก็ตกลงมาเป็นก้อนเลยนะไม่
ใช่หิมะนะถ้าแบบหิมะเนี่ยยังเล็กๆนะอย่าง
ประเทศนักเรียนเนาะนะก็จะมีหิมะเย็นๆแล้ว
ก็ไปเล่น
สกีไปเล่นสโนว์บอร์ด
ใชมูปุ๊กแต่ครูชิเนี่ยเคยเคยดูทีวีแล้วเ
บอกว่าถ้าโลกใบนี้นะถ้าโลกใบนี้เนี่ยอืม
แล้วมี
อุณหภูมิมากขึ้นแค่ 1 องศาเซลเซียเนี่ย
ข้างบนเนี่ยจะเป็นน้ำแข็งใช่มั้ยก็จะ
เปลี่ยนเป็นน้ำค่ะแล้วน้ำก็จะ
ท่วมท่วมโลกอืจริงมะเชื่อมั้เอ้าคูชิมัน
ก็อาจจะเป็นไปได้เพราะว่าก็มีคนเนี่ยเขา
ไปดูไปเช็คเนาะน้ำแข็งตั้งแต่ขั้วโลก
เหนือขั้วโลกใต้เนี่ยนะเข้าใจเอ่อขั้วโลก
เนี่ยหมายถึงจุดข้างบนเนาะแล้วก็ขั้วโลก
เหนือขั้วโลกใต้นะบริเวณนี้เนี่ยจริงๆมัน
ก็จะมีน้ำแแข็งเนาะแล้วก็น้ำแข็งที่เป็น
ภูเขาน้ำแข็งเลยนะแล้วคิดดูว่าภูเขาน้ำ
แข็งเนี่ยถ้ามันละลายลงมาเป็นน้ำทั้งหมด
น่ะโอ้โหน้ำเป็นจะเยอะขนาด
ไหนแล้วโลกของเราเนี่ยโลกของเรามีน้ำใช่
มยเป็นน้ำเนี่ย 3 ส่วนอืเป็นแผ่น
ดินแ่นวี้ต่างๆเนยุโรปอเมริกาเหนือ
อเมริกาใต้ประเทศเอเชียอย่างเงี้ย 1 ส่วน
อ้าครูปุ๊กดูแผนที่ดิน้ำ้ำ้ำเนี่ยมี 3
ใช่มั้ยน้ำเยอะมากสีฟ้าน้ำก็เยอะอยู่แล้ว
มีแผ่นดินเนี่ยนิดหน่อยนี่แผ่นดินแผ่นดิน
แผ่นดินอืเนาะ
เออเนาะครูชิแต่ครูปุ๊กก็คิดว่าเป็นไปได้
นะคะน้ำอาจจะท่วมโลกก็ได้เพราะว่าประเทศ
ไทยเนี่ยก็เราคิดว่าเมื่อกนเก่อนนะน
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยเราก็อาจจะมีน้ำทะเลเนี่ย
ท่วม
นะประเทศไทยจะหายไปประเทศไทยเมื่อก่อน
เป็นทะเลค่ะ
เพราะว่าเราขุดลงไปในดินเนี่ยเราเจอ
ฟอสซิลที่เป็นเปลือกหอยใช่มั้ยมีเปลือก
หอยเปลือกหอยตอนนี้เนี่ยนะอยู่แบบอีสาน
อย่างเงี้ยเจอซาก
ไดโนเสารนะ
กูชิเคยขึ้นไปบนยอดเขานะคะแล้วก็เห็น
ฟอสซิลที่เป็นหอยอ่ะอยู่บนภูเขาก็แสดงว่า
เมื่อก่อนมันอยู่อยู่ใต้ทะเลเหรอคะเมื่อ
ก่อนมันอยู่ในน้ำแล้วมันก็ดันขึ้นมาเป็น
ภูเขาข้างบนใช่มันจะจริงหรออืเ้าไม่อย่าง
งั้นเปลือกหอยจะมายังไงมีใครจะเอาเปลือก
หอยเนี่ยไปไว้ข้างบนมั้ยหรือมีคนขึ้น
[ปรบมือ]
กินมีคนเอาขึ้นไปกินหรือเปล่าโอ๊ยทำไมเ้า
ไม่กินข้างล่างไปนั่งกินข้างบนทำไมอ่ะแต่
ถ้าสสมมตินะเหมือนเหมในหนังที่พูดถึงว่า
น้ำเนี่ยจะท่วมโลกท่วมโลกใบนี้ใช่มั้ย
แล้วก็จะมีโนอาใช่มั้ยเูชิก็ดูหนังมา
เหมือนกันนะคะโนอาก็จะสร้างเรือค่ะเรือลำ
ใหญ่เรือของโนอาโนอาเนี่ยมีเรืออยู่แล้ว
เพราะว่าพระเจ้าเนี่ยนะเห็นว่าโนอาเนี่ย
นะนับถือพระเจ้าใช่มยเชื่อมั่นในพระเจ้า
ก็เลยให้มีโอกาสรอดใช่มั้ยนะรอดตายไม่ตาย
เนี่ยนะก็เลยให้สร้างเรือนะมีเรือโนอา
เรือรำใหญ่เนี่ยสำหรับให้สัตว์ขึ้นไปแล้ว
ก็มีคนขึ้นไปคนที่จะมีชีวิตรอดก็คือไม่
ตายน่าเห็นมยสัตว์นี้ก็จะมี 2 ตัวตัวผู้ 1
ตัวตัวเมีย 1 ตัวเราเรียกว่า 1 คู่นะม้า
คู่หนึ่งช้างคู่หนึ่งหมาคู่หนึ่งนะฮะเอา
ไป 1 คู่อย่างละ 1 คู่ใช่มั้ยที่จะได้
ขึ้นเรือโนอาอแล้วถ้าเกิดโนอาบอกว่าเอ้า
ูชิปะเออแต่ครูชิไม่ต้องหาคู่
ค่ะครูชิเนี่ยนะให้ครูชิไปไม่ให้สามีไป
ไม่ให้คนอื่นไป
แต่เป็นคนดีเหรอคะถูกเลือกใช่นะเป็นคนดี
นะนะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยโนอาบอกว่าถ้าอย่าง
งั้นเนี่ยอนุญาตเพราะว่าเรือเนี่ยจะน้ำ
หนักมากไม่ได้เราจะเอาเสื้อผ้าเอาของกิน
ของใช้อะไรขึ้นไปเนี่ยไม่ได้นะเพราะว่า
เรือเนี่ยก็มีการจำกัดน้ำหนักเหมือนกัน
เนาะนะเรือหนักเกินไปก็จมแล้วก็จะได้ให้
คนอื่นมีโอกาสไปด้วย
เออนะแล้วถ้าูชิเนี่ยนะถ้าพวกเราได้ไป
เนาะนะแล้วโนอาบอกว่าเอาของไปได้สัก 3
อย่างนะ 1 คนเนี่ยคุณสามารถเอาของสิ่งของ
อะไรก็ได้ไป 3 อย่างครูชี้เนี่ยจะเอาอะไร
ไปคะโอ้โหเอาไป 3 อย่างเองหรอคะโอ้โหเค้า
จำกัดน้ำหนักค่ะเหมือนขึ้นเครื่องบินเห็น
มเค้าก็จำกัดน้ำหนักเอ่อมีเงินอันนี้เค้า
ก็ไม่ให้นะไปบอกว่าเออขอซื้อน้ำหนัก
เหมือนเครื่องบินอันนี้ไม่ให้นะ
คะเออูชิก็ต้องแบบเอาต้นไม้ค่ะอ่ะเดี๋ยวๆ
ๆๆเอาไปทำไมต้ไม้เอ้าก็เผื่อเราจะไปกิน
ผักกินต้นไม้ที่เรากินได้ก็ต้องนึกนะเรา
จะเอาต้นอะไรดีนะที่มันกินได้
อ๋อไม่ใช่เอาเม็ดไปปลูกใช่มยไม่เอาเม็ดไป
ปูกูชิว่าูชิจะเอาเอาต้นกล้วย
เออเอาต้นกล้วยค่ะครูปุ๊กทำไมต้นกล้วยเอา
ต้นกล้วยเล็กๆก็ได้อ่ะอ่าเอาหน่อกล้วยไป
ก็ได้
นะถ้ากล้วยโตแล้วกล้วยจะได้มีลูกมีลูกมี
ลูกมีลูกเอออันเนี้ยครูชิเก็บกินเออเนาะ
เพราะว่าจริงๆแล้วอ่ะกินกล้วยเนี่ยก็อิ่ม
เหมือนกันอืครูชิจะเป็นลิง
ค่ะเพราะว่ามีทั้งคาร์โบไฮเดรตมีทั้ง
วิตามินนะเพราะว่าตอนเด็กๆเราก็ต้องให้
กินกล้วยเหมือนกันเนาะนะแล้วก็กล้วยเนี่ย
ที่สำคัญก็คือเวลากล้วยเนี่ยมันโตๆๆแล้ว
มีลูกใช่มยมีเครือนะมีเครือเป็นหวีวีี
เนี่ยก็ออกทีนึงเนี่ยมันก็จะมีหวีหลายๆ
หวีเนาะนะเพราะกล้วยเนี่ยมันไม่ได้ออกแค่
ลูกเดียวไม่เหมือนแอปเปิ้ลแอปเปิ้ลเนี่ย
ลูกเดียวทุเรียนเนี่ยลูกนึงลูกนึงคือ
อันเนี้ย 1 นะออกมา 1  1 เครือเนี่ยโอ้โห
มีไม่รู้กี่
หวี 1 หวีก็มีไม่รู้กี่ลูกูชิแล้วมันออก
ตลอด
ปีมันออกลูกได้ตลอดปีแต่ครูปุ๊กต้องแบบมี
มีกล้วยใช่มยเอาเอาต้นกล้วยเล็กๆเนี่ยแต่
ต้นกล้วยเนี่ยต้องใส่กระถางไป
นะมี
ดินนะแล้วเวลากล้วยเนี่ยมันมันโตแล้วมัน
ออกดอกแล้วเนี่ยนะนมันก็จะแทงยอดหน่อใหม่
นะจะมีหน่อใหม่เล็กๆขึ้นมาเรื่อยๆค่ะแล้ว
กล้วยเนี่ยเป็นต้นไม้ที่ไม่ค่อยเราไม่
ต้องดูแลมากอ่ะอืนะไม่ต้องต้องไปคอยดูแล
ไม่ต้องไปดูว่าแมลงมากินมหรืออะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยมันจะไม่ค่อยมีปัญหามากไม่ต้องดูแล
มากเนาะแล้วแล้วต้องใส่กระถางที่เอาดินไป
เนี่ยเพราะว่าถ้าเกิดน้ำท่วมโลกเนี่ยครู
ชิดูเคยดูหนังค่ะดูหนัง Wat  World ไง
โอ้โหดินเนี่ยมีราคาเพราะว่าทุกคนไม่เคย
เห็นดินมันโลกใบนี้จะมีแต่น้ำไปหมดเลยเออ
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยต้องเอาดินไปด้วยค่ะเอา
ต้นกล้วยเอาดินติดไปค่ะอือืเนาะจะได้มี
อาหารกินอื
โอ้ปุ๊กนะคะอย่างที่ 1 เนี่ยเราเอาอะไรไป
ครูปุ๊กเอาอะไรไปที่ครูปุ๊กต้องเอาไป
เนี่ยครูปุ๊กคิดว่าต้องเป็นมีดค่ะมีด
เนี่ยสำคัญค่ะ
เอามีดไปทำอะไรคะอ๋อเรามีม้า 2 ตัวมีช้าง
ตัวเราไปเชือดมันเหรอไม่ใช่อแต่ว่าเวลา
ไม่ว่าเราจะทำอะไรเนาะมันก็ต้องมี
เอ่อมีดเอาไปสำหรับถ้าเราไปเจอแผ่นดินเรา
ไปเจอต้นไม้เราก็ใช้มีดได้หรือว่าเราเจอ
อาหารใช่มั้ยเออเราก็ต้องใช้มีดค่ะ
นะครูปุคิดมีดสำคัญใช่เอ้าครูชิว่ามันไม่
สำคัญเหรอคะถ้าเกิดอ้าสมัยก่อนเราก็ไม่มี
มีด
ค่ะสมัยที่เราอยู่บนโลกนี้ที่ที่แรกเรามี
แต่ก้อนหินมีดเป็นสิ่งที่คนเนี่ยทำขึ้นมา
ใช่มยนี่เลยสมัยก่อนก็ไม่มีมีดนะครูปุ๊ก
ไม่มีแต่มันจะยุ่งยากแล้วก็ทำความลำบาก
ให้ไงก็คือกว่าจะทำอะไรได้มันต้องใช้เวลา
บางคนอาจจะแบบเอาเปลือกหอยเนไปถูถถจนแบบ
มันคมอะไรอย่างเงี้ยนะมันมันมันเสียเวลา
ค่ะหรือว่าจะกินปลาแล้วก็จะเอาอะไรอ่ะเอา
เปือกหอยได้มยหรืออะไรไปตัดปลามันก็ยากไง
ูชิแต่ถ้าเรามีมีดเนี่ยมันง่ายมันสะดวกทำ
ให้เราเนี่ยสบายมากขึ้นครูปุ๊ก็เลยจะเอา
มีดไปใช่มีดก็เลยเป็นสิ่งสำคัญอย่างนึง
เนาะไม่ว่าเราไปเจอต้นไม้แล้วเราอยากจะทำ
บ้านทำที่อยู่มันก็ต้องแบบตัดหรือว่าอะไร
อย่างเงี้ยหรือว่าทำอาหารน่ะมีผักมีอะไร
ก็ต้องหั่นใช่มยอืุก็เลยคิดมีดก็มีความ
สำคัญนะไม่อย่างงั้นน่ะครูชิเห็นมั้ยพวก
ไม่ว่าจะเป็นโจรสลัดใช่
มยเหมือนอะไรนะ Private  of  the  carian
ใช่มยแจ็ค SP โจรสลัดเห็นมออทุกคนเนี่ยจะ
ต้องมีมีดใช่มย
ออดเอ้อเผื่อเราไปเจอเรือลำอื่นเราจะได้
เป็นโจรสลัด
มีใช่เราก็เอาไว้ทำอะไรอ่ะเป็นอาวุธได้ทำ
อาเวลาจะทำอาหารก็ใช้มีดได้ไงโอคือที่
เป็นโจรสลัดแล้ว
อ้าวไม่ใช่
มีดตึงสำหรับสำหรับไว้สำหรับอะไรอ่ะเราจะ
เป็นโจรสลัดต้องมีมีดไม่เเห็นมยแล้วมัน
เป็นความสำคัญมันมันต้องสำคัญไงไม่อย่าง
งั้นเจะพกมีดทำไมล่ะไม่ว่าจะไปตัดอะไรมัน
ก็ต้องใช้มีดใช่มยหรือไปขู่คนอื่นฮ่ากลัว
มั้ยเออเห็นมยมันก็ต้องต่อสู้ก็ต้องใช้
มีดเห็นมั้ยูชิอืเพียงแต่เขาเป็นมีดไง
มีดมันก็จะยาวกว่าูคิดถึงอาหาร
ค่ะประหยัดเวลาอาหารประหยัดเวลา
ูชิคิดถ้าเกิดเอ่อต้นกล้วยครูชิเเนี่ยยัง
ไม่โตูชิต้องมีอันนี้ค่ะ
ข้าวเอาข้าวสารไปค่ะ
อืเอาไปทำไมหรือหรือเอาข้าวเปลือกดีเอา
ข้าวที่มีเปลือก
ค่ะข้าวข้าวที่มีเปลือกเนี่ยสามารถใส่ลง
ไปในดินนี้กลายเป็นต้นข้าว
อ่าแล้วก็จะได้ข้าวเปลือกมาใหม่
อืแต่ขณะที่ข้าวยังไม่โตก็เอาข้าวเนี่ยย
มาหุงแล้วก็กินไงแล้วครูชิต้องเลือกเป็น
ข้าว
เหนียวข้าวเหนียวทำไมอ่ะเพราะว่าข้าว
เหนียวเนี่ยเวลากินแล้วมันอิ่มนาน
แล้วมันเก็บได้นานไงแห้งๆเก็บเอาไว้มาถึง
เวลาหิวก็ปั้นกลมๆเล็กๆ 1 คำ
อืแต่ครูชิคะถ้าค่ะครูชิจะมีข้าวเหนียว
เนี่ยครูชิอ่ะไม่ก็ต้องก่อไฟก่อนสิ
คะใช่มยต้องจุดไฟถึงจะหุงข้าวเหนียวได้
อื้อหือนะแล้วครูชี้จุดุดไฟยังไงโอ้โหครู
ปุ๊กครูทิก็ต้องเอาไฟไปด้วยสิ
เอ้อนี่เลยค่ะครูปุ๊ก็เตรียมไปเหมือนกัน
แต่ว่าเป็นตัวนี้นะเป็นแบบที่ยิงเฉยๆนะ
เพราะว่าถ้าเอาูคิดว่าถ้าเอาไฟแช็คไปน้ำ
มันหมดทำยัง
ไงอันนี้เพหมดเหมือนกันเอ้าอันนี้มันแก๊ก
ๆๆมันยิงง่ายๆไงเออยิงง่ายใช่มยแล้วก็ไม่
ใช่แบบโอโหถ้าให้ครูบุ๊กไปเอาก้อนหินก้อน
หินมาแล้วก็ึใส่กันให้มันเกิดประกายไฟ
แล้วติดที่ใบไม้เนี่ยครูุคิดว่าไม่ได้กิน
ค่ะวันเนี้ยหรือเอาไม้มาหมุนๆๆโอ้โหหมุนๆ
ๆๆๆๆแบบนี้ให้มันเป็นไฟใช่มอืนี่ไงครูทิ
ถึงแบบอยากเอากล้วยไปไงเพราะว่ากล้วย
เนี่ยกินได้ง่ายๆไม่ต้องใช้มีดค่ะปอกก็
กินได้เลยอแล้วก็ไม่ต้องใช้ไฟหุงเด็ดออก
มาแล้วก็กินได้เลยเออเออแต่มันจะมีไม่พอ
กินไงครูชิเพราะว่าถึงมันจะครูชิแค่
กระถางเล็กๆเนาะแต่ถ้าปลูกตามบ้านเนี่ย
จากต้นนึงมันก็จะออกหน่อนะขึ้นมาเรื่อยๆ
นะเดี๋ยวก็โตใช่มั้ยต้นนี้เนี่ยตัดแล้ว
ตัดทิ้งไปนะต้นที่เป็นนอมามันก็ค่อยๆสูง
ขึ้นไปเรื่อยๆค่ะพอถึงเวลาใกล้จะออกดมัน
ก็จะมีนอขึ้นมาเรื่อยๆนะมีหน่อไม่ใช่มีนอ
นะหน่อไม้หน่อหน่อของกล้วยหน่อกล้วยหน่อ
ไม้อืนะคะหน่อถ้านจะเป็นของแรดค่ะนแรดน
ข้าวก็คิดคิดว่าเอาข้าวไปปลูกกล้วยก็ปลูก
ไว้กินข้าวก็ปลูกไว้กินเอแล้วถ้าครูชิเอา
ไปได้นะครูปุ๊กอย่างที่ 3 เนี่ยครูชิจะ
เอาเอาอะไร
คะเมล็ดพืชค่ะ
อ๋อคือเม็ดของมันที่จะเอาไปปลูกใช่มั้ย
ใช่ให้ปลูกออกมาเป็นมะม่วงเออเม็ด
มะม่วงปลูกออกมาเป็นพริกปลูกออกมาเนี่ย
เป็น
ผักผัก
บุ้งผักดกาด
หอมผักส้มเออผักกาดขาวได้หมดลูกทุกอย่าง
ใช่มยเป็นมันจะเป็นมีเมล็ดให้เราไปปลูก
ได้ใช่มั้ยเจะทำตอนนี้เ้ามีขายเป็นซอง
เนอะมีซองที่เป็นกระดาษใช่มยซองกระดาษ
แล้วก็ใส่เมล็ดผักไว้ขายใน
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตก็มีนะนะสำหรับเอาไปปลูก
ออูชิจะเอาเมล็ดพืชไปเพราะว่าูชินึกถึง
เวลาช่วงที่แบบตอน
เอ่ออะไรนะ
อเรามีเรามีเรือแล้วก็ไปหาแผ่นดินแล้วก็
ไปเจอโคลัมบัสอ่ะเอาเรือออกไปอ่ะแล้วไป
เจออเมอริกาอืคนที่ไปเนี่ยก็ไม่รู้จะกิน
อะไรไงแล้วก็มีชาวเผ่า
ยอินเดียแดงอือินเดียแดงก็มาสอนสอนให้ทุก
คนเนี่ยปลูกผักปลูกฟักทองจำได้มยปลูกฟัก
ทองเอามาทำฮาโลวีนเหรอคะปลูกข้าว
โพดเอามาทำป๊อปคอร์น
เออมันก็เลยเป็นวันแบบ thanksgiving ไงอื
อ่าเพราะว่ามีอาหารเห็นมั้ยูชิก็เลยคิดไง
อย่างแรกเนี่ยต้องมีเมล็ดมาปลูกเป็นอาหาร
ค่ะอือือแล้วก่อนที่จะไปหาแผ่นดินเจอ
เนี่ยนะมันจะได้ปลูกเมื่อไหร่คะครูชิแล้ว
แต่ละอย่างมันต้องใช้เวลาในการเจริญเติบ
โตเราต้องใช้ดินนิดหน่อยแยกออก
มามันจะปลูกได้มยเออแต่อาหารที่เราต้อง
กินทุกวันค่ะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยอย่างสุด
ท้ายที่ครูปุ๊กจะเตรียมไปเนี่ยก็
คืออ
คือคือคือมีสัตว์อยู่ในเรืออยู่แล้วครู
ปุ๊กช้างม้า
วัวหมูนี่ค่ะเรานั่งเรือเนี่ยมันก็จะต้อง
มีปลาใช่มั้ยมีอาหารที่เป็นซีฟู้ดหรือ
อาหารทะเลค่ะเพราะฉะนั้นเราก็เตรียมเบ็ด
ตกปลาพร้อมกับเหยื่อค่ะใช้เหยื่อปลอม
เนี่ยเห็นมั้ยอื้อหือนะเบ็ดตกปลาก็เอาแบบ
ของฝรั่งเนี่ยมีรอกมีรอกหมุนด้วยเอาไปตก
ปลากินใช่อยู่บเรืออใช่ไม่มีข้าวก็ยังกิน
ปลาได้ไงนะ
กุ้งโอ้โหกินได้ทุกอย่างค่ะนะก็ต้องมี
เบ็ดตกปลามีรอกเนแล้วก็มีเหยื่อปลอมค่ะนะ
มีเหยื่อปลอมนี่มีเหยื่อปลอมนะมีปลาปลอม
เนี่ยเหยื่อปลอมนะแล้วก็ออเรารู้ว่าปลา
ตัวใหญ่ๆชอบกินปลาตัวเล็กๆเราก็เลยทำปลา
ตัวเล็กๆเนี่ยมาเป็นเหยื่อสำหรับล่อมามา
กินชันมากินชันันแล้วพอปลาตัวใหญ่มากิน
ปุ๊บอ้าก็ติดเบ็ดของเราถูกต้องค่ะไอ้นี่
ไงเนี่ยเบ็ดเนี่ยนะเกี่ยวเข้าไปเนี่ย
โอ้โหนะดิ้นหนียังไงก็ไม่หลุดค่ะ
เจ็บนะเราเราก็จะได้ปลามากินอใช่นะครู
ปุ๊กก็เลยคิดว่าที่สำคัญก็คือนะครูปุ๊กก็
เลยคิดมีเบ็ดตกปลาใช่มั้ยมีมีดมีไฟค่ะทำ
อาหารกินได้
แล้วส่วนของูชิเนี่ยมีกระถางต้นกล้วยมี
ข้าวเปลือกแล้วก็มีเมล็ดพืชสำหรับไปปลูก
ผักนะูชิเน้นแต่คาร์โบไฮเดรตค่ะนัก
เรียนูชิเน้นว่าเด็ดแล้วก็กินได้เลยอิ่มๆ
ไม่ต้องไปทำ
อาหารไม่ต้องใช้ไฟใช่มนักเรียนบอกว่าผัก
กินอืถ้าตกตกปลามาก็กินเป็นปลาดิบได้ค่ะ
ซาชิมิแต่ครูปุกมีไฟไงอาฮะก็แล้วแต่เราไง
แต่จริงๆูไม่ชอบกินของดิบครูุ๊ก็เลยคิด
ถึงไฟกูปุ๊กก็ไปกินปลาเผาใช่เอาปลาไปเผา
แล้วก็ไม่ต้องใช้มีดขอดเก็ดค่ะคุณปุ๊กปลา
ไปเผาเนี่ยแล้วก็ค่อยลอกลอกหนังออกค่ะอื
ลอกหนังปลาก็จะมีปลาเนื้อปลาขาวๆอ่ะดูๆดู
ูชิเนี่ยพูดไปก็น้ำ
ลายน้ำลายไหลค่ะน้ำลายไหลเลยเห็นมยเพราะ
ว่าภาพใช่มยจินตนาการ
นักเรียนรู้เลยว่า 2 คนเนี้ยคิดแต่เรื่อง
กินค่ะพอบอกว่าให้คิดอะไร 3 อย่างเอาขึ้น
ไปบนเรือเนี่ยสเอ่อ 2 คนเนี้ยคิดกิน
อะไรทำอะไรกินได้เออเออจะหามายังไงเออนะ
ก็ก็เลยแบบไม่รู้นะว่าของนักเรียนเนี่ย
ถ้าให้เอาไปได้ 3 อย่างเนี่ยนักเรียนจะ
เอาอะไรไปบ้าง
นะเอาอะไรขึ้นเรือโนอานะที่จะทำให้เรามี
ชีวิตรอดก็คือไม่ตายเนาะชีวิตเราก็จะรอด
อยู่ได้
อ้าเราอาจจะมันมีไก่อยู่ 2 ตัวเราก็อาจจะ
ขอขอไข่จากไก่ขอนมจากวัวมา
กินเบอกว่ามีแค่ 2 ตัว 2 คู้แบบมีแค่ 2
ตัวเองอเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยนมไม่พอให้
กินไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรวันนี้กินนมอีก 2
วันไม่กินแล้วก็รอกินวันที่ 3 อือสลับกัน
เนาะนะ
ใช่ก็วันนี้เนี่ยกินนมวัววันที่ 2 เนี่ย
กินนมแพะเวันที่ 3 เนี่ยกินนม
แเห็นมเราก็ไม่ตายแล้วมีสัตว์ไปด้วยใช่
มั้ยโนอาของเราถูกต้องนะก็วันนี้หมดเวลา
แล้วค่ะครูชิเราต้องลานักเรียนไปก่อนนะ
ค่ะนะได้ค่ะเพราะงั้นเนี่ยนักเรียนช่วย
คอมเมนต์บอกเรานะคะว่าถ้าคุณจะต้องขึ้น
เรือโนอาเนี่ยคุณอยากจะเอาอะไรไปคะ 3
อย่างจะเหมือนครูปุ๊ก
มั้ยฉันจะเอาทำไมเราไม่คิดว่าเราไปเป็น
ผู้หญิงคนเดียวเราน่าจะเอาผู้ชายหล่อๆไป
ด้วยกลัวเค้าไปแล้วเก็ยังเมินค่ะรู้สึก
แบเรื่องกินสำคัญค่ะคนไทยคนไทยบบเรื่อง
กินเรื่องยเรื่องกินสำหรับเราสำคัญมาก
กว่าใช่ค่ะใช่ค่ะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเราหมด
เวลาแล้วก็ต้องลานนักเรียนกันไปแล้วค่ะ
โอกาสหน้าพบกันนะคะอย่าลืมนะคะถ้าเป็นคุณ
จะเอาอะไรขึ้นเรือโนอา 3
อย่างต่ะสวัสดีค่ะขอบคุณสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียน